there's been a lot of hypothetical
questions on here i'm not always uh you
know a huge fan of of uh you know
guessing those things
um
but obviously i have said that before i
think that if i retire on the on the
team's
you know timeline then
all as well but uh if they're looking to
move on before i'm ready to be done
playing
you know then there there comes an
impasse at that point i can control you
know my play and my performance my
approach and my leadership but at some
point you know there's other factors
involved that's what i said you guys
you know on day one uh when we talked
about this and that's what i say to kyle
um so that's
that's the facts to me at this point
aaron rodgers
discussing his status in green bay just
a day after coach matt leflore
said that he expects aaron rodgers to be
the quarterback well into the future
well they've drafted his replacement
jordan love trading up to get him in
round one so we spent a lot of time
yesterday trying to make sense of that
which cannot be made sense of chris now
aaron rodgers a more pragmatic response
and you can tell
he's kind of said everything that he's
going to say about it right the facts
are the facts the answer is right there
we know the clock is ticking
and really at this point the only way
that it's not going to transition from
aaron rodgers to jordan love at some
point in the next four years is if aaron
rodgers goes out there and plays at an
mvp level each and every year and is in
the conversation for mvp each and every
year and even then
you feel like mark murphy the ceo of the
team at some point is going to say let's
sell high before the drop happens and
let's get high value for aaron rodgers
and hand the ball to jordan love yeah
the clock's ticking but i mean i think
those are the like you know
the scenarios where you go okay aaron
rodgers lasts in green bay more than two
years i think are you know kind of what
you said rogers has to be playing at
such a level that you just go damn we're
stupid you know we can't trade this guy
or get rid of this guy there's no way
he's still the best player on our team
so that'll be one way or of course just
even if his play does slip a little bit
and the team just continues to be really
successful maybe us you know another
super bowl appearance or a super bowl
win or you know maybe another final four
does some of that stuff extend you know
the life the lifeline of of this
marriage here between the packers but
packers and rogers but you know yeah as
it stands right now i think that's what
it takes that's what it's going to take
you know because if we get into year
three and four as we've mentioned many
times right mike i mean then you're
gonna start to like well why did you
draft this guy in the first round why
did you trade up for him what the hell
did we waste this pick to sit here for
four years and you know ultimately i
think that'll drive you know the the
brass and the organization crazy and
they're gonna want to play their guys so
those are the only scenarios i see i
don't know if you think i'm wrong or
right or what
the difference between
the patriots and jimmy garoppolo and the
packers and jordan love
is that
jimmy garoppolo had a four-year contract
because he wasn't a first-rounder so it
all came to a head
in that fourth year that was when we got
to do something because he's going to
walk away as a free agent after this
season so if we're ever going to trade
him and get real value other than a
compensatory draft pick we got to do it
now with aaron rodgers i think that
after
2021 yeah when he's got two years left
on his contract and jordan love's got
three years left technically assuming
they pick up the option and why wouldn't
they if they haven't seen him play yet
but
that's when
it begins to get awkward to the point
that you can't make the narrative go
away because i think that if they go
into 2022 the question that hovers all
year long over the packers is whether or
not this is aaron rodgers last year
because surely they're not gonna they're
not gonna continue into the fourth year
of a first round quarterback's career to
keep him on the bench because how long
was aaron rodgers on the bench yeah
three years right year four is the
action year which makes year three the
point to do it the cleanest way
the easiest way so you don't have a
season marred by this never-ending
question
of whether or not this is aaron rodgers
last year in green bay you want his last
year to already be over
without it being a major obsession
although i still think next year it's
going to be a talking point all year
long because we're looking at it saying
it probably will be his next year this
is going to this shadow is going to
hover over the franchise i agree this
time
transition yeah you're exactly they and
they
they self-inflicted the wound on
themselves no doubt no yeah i mean
you're i don't see any way out of this
conversation yeah i mean this year it'll
be
you know talked about but nobody's gonna
take it seriously right i mean i don't
think anybody's looking at it like oh
jordan love could start for the packers
or anything like that but you get into
the next off season
and you know then they start to talk
about oh what they saw from jordan love
in this past 2020 season you know
running the scout team and the things
that you know yeah these questions it's
gonna start so really this is the year
of
okay it's aaron rodgers all the way but
i think this is it to where next year
it's going to be a conversation and like
you're saying it's going to be a black
cloud a shadow over the over the
organization that people are just going
to continue to talk about ask about and
it's going to frustrate rogers i'm sure
to a degree and like he said all he can
do is go out and play really really well
and we'll see where that goes but you
know financially as we've talked about
before too it makes sense after two
years they can get out of aaron rodgers
and really cause themselves no harm
after the 2021 season and you know as it
looks right now i think bearing an mvp
or them going to the super bowl i just i
i don't the more i sit here and think
about it i don't think he'll be there
then
one thing that makes it easier for the
packers for now is the absence of
pre-season games it does we don't get to
see jordan love we're not going to see
him play at all this year potentially
unless aaron rodgers gets injured which
has happened a few times during his
career but you know we got that glimpse
of patrick mahomes in 2017. that titan's
game one of my favorite throws from him
rolling right
running full speed getting hit in the
mouth as he fires the ball down the
field i mean for me that was the moment
the light bulb went on yeah and
we're not gonna have a light bulb moment
with jordan love we're not going to know
maybe next preseason if there is one but
i think that helps keep it from being a
thing right at least until
next year if love plays in the preseason
next year if there is a pre-season
that's when maybe it'd be oh to become a
distraction but they they bought the
distraction they bought a distraction
that will last until aaron rodgers is no
longer with the packers or jordan love
is no longer with the pack no yeah it's
exactly right and i mean you know i mean
i think you're spot on but the
conversation this year i mean next year
you know
i think we both could sit here and
realistically see oh okay preseason game
two preseason game three whoa jordan
love made some good throws made some
good plays oh is this the last year for
aaron rodgers in green bay i mean that's
that's gonna start as soon as he puts it
puts together a little highlight reel
just of a few plays in the preseason all
that conversation is gonna you know
continue or fester or whatever else and
yeah they're not getting out of this one
anytime soon and you know i feel bad for
a guy like aaron rodgers that has to
deal with this a guy that's carried the
franchise on his back for this long and
here he is you know towards the end of
his career where he's still praying
playing at a high level and really has
you know i mean a box of stand on to go
i'm not playing at a level we should be
thinking about replacing me yet uh you
know i feel bad for him from that
standpoint just as a competitor
and there's a fine line chris between
providing him external motivation to get
him to finish strong in green bay and
providing him with a constant source of
torment where he's always thinking and
always wondering and yes that's very
useful if he's gonna go out and work
hard and
and put aside the scotch and the tequila
and focus on the tom brady overall
lifestyle plan to get the most out of
his body as he gets closer to age 40 and
do all the things he has to do to stave
off this competition but when he's not
acting and motivated and doing
everything he has to do to continue to
hold that job he is carrying around that
torment that unnecessary what did i do
to deserve this this is the thanks i get
for all the years that i have shown up
busted my ass made a team competitive
that shouldn't have been competitive
every year i'm turning chicken crap into
chicken salad because i don't have the
help around me and the thanks i get
is you draft my replacement you trade up
to reach for a project of a guy who is
not again just like brett favre said
after he spoke to aaron rodgers this
isn't a great quarterback who fell into
their lives this isn't tua that just
happens to be there when they're on the
clock they made the move for this guy
this is a middle finger to aaron rodgers
i mean at times he's got to think that
because that's how it should be
interpreted and that's where it's unfair
to aaron rodgers everything he's done
for that team he's going to be carrying
this baggage around every day until it
will probably be a relief for him if he
gets a chance to go play somewhere else
yeah you're right it could be it could
come to that point at some some you know
you know at some point in time where he
just goes man i'm sick of you like
having this over my shoulder and you
guys using this against me and even
having to answer these questions and hey
mike i think the big thing is this too
you know we'll see jordan love you know
i was a fan of him in the draft i mean
there's there's things i like but he's
about as raw as a first-round pick as i
have seen as far as the quarterback goes
in a long long time hey i know there was
a handful of teams you know like myself
who saw some stuff and you went ooh damn
i see some plays like aaron rodgers but
i know there was a bunch of other teams
too that were like scared to death of
jordan love and thought he was so raw
and not mentally and physically and
everything he had you know not learned
you know in college that they were
scared to death of the prospects of oh i
don't know if this guy can play for us
anytime soon or where he's at or
anything like that so that's where it's
going to be interesting too you know i
think this is a very big time boom or
bust type prospect in jordan love and
you know ultimately you're going to see
some of the brass there in green bay
held accountable for what his success
rate is
one way we would see jordan love this
year is if aaron rodgers gets injured
the other way we would see jordan love
this year is if aaron rodgers test
positive for covet 19. here's a question
that rogers was asked yesterday about
teams taking extra precautions to
protect their quarterbacks from the
coronavirus
with how important quarterbacks are in
this league
are you taking or is the team
imposing any extra precautions with you
and other quarterbacks for limiting
contact with teammates or with uh
limiting contact with people even away
from the building
yeah
not yet i'm not sure what uh
you know what the conversation will be
in the uh in the near future but uh has
it right now no
yeah not yet and you wonder when that's
gonna happen and that's one of the other
concerns and look you don't want
to treat the quarterbacks dramatically
differently than the rest of the team
but the quarterbacks get treated
dramatically differently all the time
they're protected differently during
games they are the most important guy on
the field and you do have to wonder
whether there will be extra precautions
to have like a mini bubble around aaron
rodgers and other starting quarterbacks
with other teams because yeah if you
have a great quarterback and he's gone
chris for two weeks
that may be the difference between
playoffs or no playoffs one seed or
three seed division title or wild card
no you're you're exactly right and i
mean this is a situation where if i'm
green bay i'm thinking about this long
and hard you know they got nothing
behind aaron rodgers you know no proven
commodity at all we just talked about
jordan love is raw as hell
you know i mean he's raw as hell anybody
i talked to even the ones that liked him
they told you he was raw and you could
see that on film i mean there's
decisions that are all over the place
there's throws that are all over the
place and like i said the good you go
holy crap is that good but i don't think
that's going to lead to consistency in
the nfl yet and then tim boyle their
backup i mean come on he's an unproven
commodity too so i mean if there is one
team that needs to be careful with their
starting quarterback and where that goes
and their team's success is predicated
on that starting quarterback man green
bay i mean seriously i know you love
seinfeld you know they need to start
treating aaron rodgers like bubble boy i
mean seriously i mean they need to put a
big plastic ball around him and let him
just roll around the facility and make
sure he doesn't get sick because if he
does yeah you're right he misses two
games something like that they could be
in big big trouble
and i could see at some level aaron
rodgers if he is put in self-isolation
with covet 19 just kind of sitting back
grabbing his scotch and or his sipping
tequila and saying hey
you wanted him let's go see what he can
do now yeah all right let's take a break
uh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports